[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance we are at the darkest moment
in the history of representative
government in this country James Comey
has now implied under oath that the
President of the United States is being
investigated by the Justice Department
for possible collusion with the Russian
government in tampering with the 2016
election and that the President of the
United States is also being investigated
for possible obstruction of justice
Comey said none of these things so
starkly nor directly in his testimony to
the Senate Intelligence Committee but he
might as well have the Republican
senator mr. cotton asked it bluntly do
you think Donald Trump colluded with
Russia commis reply that's a question I
don't think I should answer in an open
setting but that's a question that will
be answered by the investigation I think
logic exercise how would Special Counsel
Robert Muller answer that question by
investigating who would you investigate
to see if Trump colluded with Russia
Trump and all around him conclusion
Special Counsel lawyer is investigating
Donald Trump perhaps right now about
collusion with Russia the Republican
chairman mr. burr asked about commis
conversation with Trump about general
Flynn commis reply I don't think it's
for me to say whether the conversation I
had with the president was an effort to
obstruct I took it as a very disturbing
thing very concerning but that's a
conclusion I'm sure the Special Counsel
will work toward to try and understand
what the intention was there and whether
that's an offense second logic exercise
how can Special Counsel Robert Muller do
that by investigating who would he have
to investigate to do that Donald Trump
thus what is he investigating whether or
not Donald Trump obstructed justice even
his obstruction of justice it was
directed at least in part at James Comey
to get him at least in part as Comey
quotes Trump to let Flynn go the
Republicans senator mr. rish asked if
Trump directed Comey to do that Comey
answered not in his words no rish
followed-up did
not order you to let it go call me
answered those words are not an order
and later added I took it as a direction
this is a President of the United States
with me alone saying I hope this I took
it as this is what he wants me to do I
didn't obey that but that's the way I
took it and Comey added he was so clear
about what Trump was trying to do that
he didn't want to tell his FBI troops
what Trump had said for fear that his
words would have a chilling effect on
their investigation and for the
completion of the attempt to obstruct
justice its intended victim also had no
doubt about the cause and effect I take
the president at his word Comey said
later he added I was fired because of
the Russia investigation I was fired in
some way to change where the endeavor
was to change the way the Russian
investigation was being conducted fired
it seems not just because he would not
just close the Flint investigation but
also perhaps because he would not
publicly proclaim that Trump was
innocent of all suspicion innocent of
collusion with the Russians innocent of
everything about the election innocent
about everything in the steel dossier
down to quote hookers in Russia fired
because he was ordered in words that out
of context would not seem like an order
to close at least the Flynn
investigation in a manner which reminded
Comey of the infamous phrase attributed
to King Henry ii of england about the
Archbishop of Canterbury quoting Comey
again it rings in my ear as well will no
one rid me of this meddlesome priest
fired and left to the mercies of
Republican senators who somehow went
into this hearing seemingly thinking
that if they could get Comey just say
the Trump only tried to obstruct the
Flint investigation Trump would somehow
be vindicated who somehow went into this
hearing thinking that a Comey told Trump
there was no investigation of him in
January then Trump could not be guilty
of trying to obstruct anything who
somehow seemingly at this hearing
managed to ask questions that permitted
Comey to pronounce the most damning
things ever spoken about any president
in our history who somehow at this
hearing made it urgently necessary
to know if Trump did indeed tape his
conversations with combing tapes the
mere threat of which Comey said induced
him to reveal that he had taken his
notes on some of his conversations with
Trump in hopes that a special counsel
would then be appointed tapes about
which he testified wardie I hope there
are tapes and then later the president
surely knows if he taped me if he did my
feelings aren't hurt release all the
tapes I'm good with it
Trump's attorney the one who misspelled
president now says he believes Comey
Alba cleared Trump based on commis
testimony it looks all but certain that
the actions of the President of the
United States are under investigation
under investigation by the special
counsel on Trump and Russia from the
Justice Department under investigation
as possible collusion with the Russians
and possible attempts to obstruct
justice
perhaps under investigation at this
moment and that a target of some of that
attempt to obstruct justice completely
believed in the moment that Donald Trump
was trying to obstruct him from pursuing
justice these are the only possible
conclusions after the testimony to the
Senate Intelligence Committee by the
former FBI director James Comey resist
peace